good afternoon everybody I'll just
briefly introduce to you the
conservation programs at yo Mook
University in Jordan and under the
pressure of the 7 minute rule I just
prepare a very brief really presentation
so country like Jordan with the highest
concentration of cultural heritage sites
monument and really 200,000 accounted
for archaeological sites in the country
we had no conservation training and
teaching in the country until the year
2000 when your MOOC University took the
initiative of the establishment of a
department of conservation and
management of cultural heritage at
yarmouk University Faculty of
archaeology and anthropology and through
a joint project with the University of
Arkansas so we establish this cultural
resource management initiative in with
the University of Arkansas and in this
department we offer programs in in
conservation at different levels at
undergraduate level and at postgraduate
level now and also we offer a program in
cultural resource management so the
undergraduate program is in conservation
general conservation of cultural
heritage and we have a master program in
conservation of cultural heritage we
have master program in cultural resource
management and a master program in
archaeometry which is applied science in
in archeology well the BA in
conservation is an undergraduate program
with object we have two tracks object
conservation where a variety of
artifacts been you know considered and
we have also architectural conservation
to deal with monuments and in country
life Jordan if you have a site like
Petra you need
an army of conservators to deal with a
majestic sight like like butter and the
other sites also we provide an MA in
conservation where the focus is more on
the search as we think that in the
undergraduate we prepared the hands-on
conservators and in the master program
we really give a focus to the research
and field studies the cultural resource
management program is a special one
we're really we provide a program that
deals with the integrated management of
cultural heritage sites providing
courses and not just conservation but on
the development and the interpretation
in the presentation and in the marketing
of sites and our students and the
department have really some field
projects for example the citadel of a
man is a project developed through our
students and program and also we have an
ongoing project in n petra connecting us
to the really international world in
conservation there are many universities
from all over the world working in Petra
and our university is is there the
master in R comma tree is really a
program that deals with the application
of science in archaeology dealing with
provenance analysis authentication
dating and other related issues and is
very important and helpful for the
conservation as for the examination and
diagnostic application of science in for
archaeology for the purpose of
conservation now our future plan we are
contemplating a joint master program and
preventive conservation that will be
jointly provided with Brandenburg in
technical university of cut was in
Germany and would leiden university in
Netherlands so we'll provide this
international program in preventive
conservation the
students will take a semester at each
University and then they do their thesis
at the university of their choice also
in addition to teaching we organized
climatic training courses for students
and for employee of the Department of
Antiquities and the Ministry of Tourism
and various issues related to
conservation particularly in stone
conservation and metal conservation
that's you know run on a yearly basis we
have some lab facilities we are still
building our facilities for conservation
but we managed to get support from
through international projects and the
University to have chemical analysis lab
we have a patron epigraphy lab sampling
and molding lab we have conservation lab
of object conservation and also we have
a GIS and database management system lab
and just some snapshots of some of the
facilities that we have and we use for
training of our students this is a
typical classroom most of our students
are female students so they like to you
know work for object conservation we
have a problem when it comes to the
field conservation and architectural
conservation
and we have all variety of objects from
glass to ceramic stone and metals but
our most important challenge is really
dealing with archaeological sites
protection of these sites and managing
of this site is really a real challenge
thank you very much